some of the largest national newspapers
reported a sharp jump in online
subscriptions last year after the 2016
presidential race but a Pew study finds
the industry as a whole so advertising
revenue plunged by nearly a third in the
past decade the industry now wants
Congress to take action by allowing them
to renegotiate how content is shared on
Facebook and Google in a new Wall Street
Journal op-ed David Chevron argues
Facebook and Google present an enix
inexorable threat to an economically
squeezed industry he is president and
CEO of the news media Alliance a trade
association representing around 2000
digital and print outlets in the United
States and Canada welcome great thank
you very much for having me what's the
threat the threat is you know even
though people are consuming more news
than ever people consume more hard News
than ever in history but that is good
that's great for democracy but they
consume it differently they consume it
online and the problem is that when they
consume it online the money isn't
flowing to the folks who are hiring the
reporters and if we need a system that
allows the folks hiring the reporters to
be able to produce the great content
that we need in this country break it
down for everybody who's not in our
industry what's happening if there's an
article for instance on CBS news.com
it gets shared on Facebook but who's
getting the advertising revenue well
most of the advertising revenue is going
to Google and Facebook as a matter of
fact those two together have over
seventy percent of all the digital ad
revenue out there and so they're getting
the content for free effectively and you
know part of that is a newspaper thing
we had a history of giving away content
for free and now we've got to say hey
this is a business too in the sense that
we've got to pay people so these
discussions have been going on sorry
with news organizations in Facebook and
Google already what has been their
response I think they're try they're
indicating that they're trying to help
publishers but it hasn't been very much
very fast okay and we're in a kind of
moment where something needs to be done
Facebook and Google both tell us they're
committed to helping and working with
news publishers and those platforms help
newspapers get content out to a wider
audience why should they be
to negotiate the way they operate that's
when those two listen this is important
to everybody right news is not just
content news is what's tying together
our democracy and now more than ever I
think people understand that news if you
get fake news if you get news garbage
news it impacts the whole of society so
this is one of the situations where we
need to figure out a solution for the
future in the news but okay with this
inexorable threat that you talk about
what's your solution the solution is we
need a better deal from Facebook and
Google among others a better economic
deal and also one of the big things is
brand people going on Facebook often
think that when they read on Facebook
the Facebook has produced the content
people said I read that news on Facebook
so they don't know if it's CBS or Wall
Street Journal or CNN exactly or
somebody who didn't know what they were
talking about yeah so you know one of
the great I mean we all have crazy
uncles right I got a bunch of them that
would give you a conspiracy theories
over the dining room table and that's
uncle bub and that's different from
what's in the paper lands on the
driveway right yeah now it gets now the
crazy conspiracy theory and the news
peels is Federer just not willing to
agree to this so you suggesting
government should step in and force no I
think what we're interesting ly under it
gets complicated under the antitrust
laws the newspapers currently can't get
together to negotiate with these giants
and what we're just asking is the
ability to negotiate as a group that's
all isn't that an uphill battle though
David it's like and when you're on the
airline and now you've got to pay for
legroom and now you have to pay for an
extra bag if we've been getting it for
free why do I now why would they what is
their incentive to now pay well there it
is an uphill battle I get that but also
I know what the free news business is
you know if you want a free news
business it's Pope endorses Trump right
it's fake news world people wanted to
know about the about the world but if
you don't have a business sustaining it
underneath you're going to get garbage
and it's in everybody's interest that we
have a future for the news business you
reached out to them we have and you know
it's there a great bird take your call
there are a great distribution they all
right they reach yeah hundreds of
millions of people Facebook reaches two
billion users
and that's a hoobie that's a great thing
for getting news out right but and again
the audience for the news product is
bigger than ever and that's a great
thing the other part we need to get to
is you know we need to pay reporters and
things like that to produce the great
content and that great content is you
think Facebook and Google are killing
small local newspapers I don't think
that's their intent I think there's a
there's been a big shift to online and
there's not an online model yet that's
really sustaining the future of the news
business and we got to create one
because that's where it's been ongoing
conversation thank you thank you very
much John they don't pay the reporters
thank you David Avrin very much